okay I have a question for you listen to
these clips from three different songs
and try to guess what they all have in
common could you figure it out whether
directly or indirectly all of these
songs were inspired in some way by blues
music but how are all these songs that
sounds so different
influenced by the same music and what
makes blues music the blues
you don't like the blues you don't like
your mama convinced Tallulah music name
it's like cooking potatoes you may
surround you may bake them you may cut
them up
you may smash it but there's still
potatoes pretty guitar solos wailing
harmonicas and soulful lyrics about
life's hardships are all part of what
makes people love the blues but how did
this music start and why is it so
important to American music the answer
to this question can be found deep in
the Mississippi Delta of the American
South where the blues was born sometime
in the late 1800s even after slavery
officially ended poverty and unjust laws
kept people from full freedom many
former slaves stayed in the south and
continued to work in difficult
conditions people sang spirituals at
church and work songs in the field to
help deal with the daily struggles over
time this music developed into what
people now call the blues most blues
musicians were farm workers by day and
would play at blues bars called juke
joints by night the earliest form of the
booze was often referred to as country
blues or Delta blues and this style
usually had a solo singer who would also
either play the harmonica or bottle next
slide guitar bottleneck slide guitar is
when a musician presses a hard object
across multiple strings on a guitar and
slides it down the fingerboard sometimes
they would use a steel bar a knife or a
bottleneck and this would create a
smooth wailing type of sound
[Music]
the delta blues also emphasized rhythm
finger style guitar and reflective
lyrics about the hard lives of African
American farmers in the South as blues
music grew in popularity some musicians
like Charlie Patton Eddie James son
house jr. and Robert Johnson became
famous and turned around the Delta
region later blues musicians started
performing in Memphis Tennessee to
establish their careers
this included famous blues men like BB
King and John Lee Hooker doing what's
known as the great migration from 1910
to 1970 millions of African Americans
tried to escape the racism and Jim Crow
laws of the south by moving to northern
cities many moved to the city of Chicago
in particular these musicians like
Howlin wolf Willie Dixon and Muddy
Waters made this journey and brought the
Blues with them they also developed the
new Chicago blues sound Chicago blues
was basically the same style of blues
played in the Delta
except played more energetically with an
electric guitar sometimes a bass guitar
piano and drums listen to this clip from
Robert Johnson's Delta blues style song
I believe out dust my broom recorded in
1936 now listen to a 1966 version of the
same song in a more Chicago style by
Howlin wolf
[Music]
now this chicago-style would later have
an influence on rock-and-roll but we'll
talk more about that later what gives
you the Blues in RA when they run out of
peanut butter jelly oh wow you know me
really well know how much experience do
you have playing the Blues that is a
very interesting question because it's
also asking me how much experience do I
have playing gospel rock and roll all
intertwined
yeah actually did an episode on my
channel on the Blues a year ago and
since then I've learned a lot about
blues okay about the Blues as a genre
and also the form how would you say
blues music and your realm of classical
music are related the way that melody is
formed over chords how it's elaborating
upon different chords that are different
chord progression I think that's where
the similarity is going so what is it
that makes blues music sound bluesy well
let's take a look at the scale that's
most commonly found in blues songs which
is a six note scale based off of a five
note scale that 5 note scale either
being the major pentatonic scale
or the minor one
and as you can hear these five not
skills are quite different than the
seven not scales that you most commonly
hear in western music now going back to
the major pentatonic scale to that we're
going to add a flat three from the root
note städel sound like this
to the minor one we're going to add the
flat five from the root note and that'll
sound like this
another important part of the blues is
the form and most blues will follow a
12-bar blues chord progression which is
based around three different courts
those chords in C major will be C the
one chord F the four chord and G the
five chord and these chords will be
repeated in a specific order most
commonly with a flat seven as well so a
c7 f7 and g7 and that'll sound like this
c7 for four measures three for f7 for to
[Music]
c7 for to g7 for one f7 for one and back
to C 7 for tune
[Music]
of course improvisation is a huge part
of the blues and no tune is complete
without it so I'm going to give it a
shot
[Music]
is there something that is similar to
what a Blue Note is in terms of pitches
in the context of just drums absolutely
with pitch is like if you're playing in
between a C and a c-sharp that there's a
note in between the Sienna c-sharp a
Blue Note and rhythm would be like if
it's directly on the beat or there's
things that there's notes in between the
quantized beats that you could still
ride with another important element of
Blues is it's a a B lyrical structure
let's go back to the Robert Johnson
track I believe are dust my broom now do
you know what lyrics come next it's the
first line repeated this a a B lyrical
structure is very common in the blues
it's inspired by the call-and-response
style of singing in african-american
spirituals and work songs in the blues
the first line is often repeated and the
third line answers of course what the
lyrics are about is also important now
true blue lives absolutely true saying
about a life experience sometime good
sometimes bad didn't lie as blues
musicians move from the south and took
their music to different parts of the US
the blues mixed with other musical
styles from those regions and helped
inspire meaning new genres the 12-bar
blues chord progression became one of
the most popular forms for early jazz
improvisation jazz performers like Louis
Armstrong Duke Ellington and Miles Davis
were all influenced by the booze often
using a 12-bar structure for their songs
[Music]
the 12-bar structure was also a major
influence on rock and roll some even
call rock-and-roll blues with a backbeat
and Elvis Presley probably had this in
mind when he recorded his version of a
blues song by Big Mama Thornton called
hound dog blues also inspired other rock
and pop artists such as all of these
songs use some form of the 12-bar
structure or the blues scale the
pentatonic and blue scales are even
common throughout heavy metal music
[Music]
country music - in fact country is
thought to be the result of blues music
mixing with folk music brought by
European immigrants to the US because of
this many country songs are written with
the blue scale or following the 12-bar
blues progression
[Music]
blues here we go please
I was thinking we don't have to do
classic blues we'll just have our own
twist to it
that's what it is we just gotta let
creation happen I mean we always do
so our song contains the 12 bar blues
chord progression as well as the blues
scale and some other elements of the
blues were included but with our own
twist
for example the whaling type of sound of
the bottle next slide guitar got
translated into this type of synth sound
which I think has this squiggle and has
that wailing quality and obviously the
other parts are quite not traditional
but we try to go with sounds that have
this laid-back yet yearning type of
quality
[Music]
let us know what you think of our blues
inspired song and make sure you don't
forget to subscribe 3 is the one he's
the one yep
[Music]
you